breeding science lesson before movie
mysteries of gravity why anyone is
impressed with a zero-g film 45 years
after being impressed with 2001 a Space
Odyssey with this lawyer movie expects
us to believe any woman would run off on
George Clooney accused to be
misinterpreting the data we're not
receiving any is it data or data can get
on the same page at least knowing your
system and Avila's the purpose of this
version and exposition is the purpose of
this line of dialogue mysteries of
gravity why Bullock a medical doctor is
servicing the Hubble Space Telescope
bankroll prototypes for your pretty blue
eyes you're flying around space on a
prototype remember silence I can get
used to it since when have you heard
silence since you've been up here with
Houston breathing down your neck about
your health and Kowalski telling stories
about his ex-wife and playing country
music and the other side is playing with
his tether oh recess you haven't had one
minute of silence but a ball and a
doctor stop I can't the board is still
initializing have you ever been so
frustrated getting something to work
that you ignored the description of
flying debris coming at you like a
speeding bullet and the direct order to
stop doing the work the film gravity
depicts a scenario of catastrophic
satellite destruction that can actually
happen half a North America just lost
their Facebook this is not a bad thing
this happens for quite some time so go
ahead and get your refill of popcorn and
soda here
nightmare fodder Kowalski how do you
copy
mysteries of gravity satellite
communications are disrupted at 230
miles up but communication satellites
orbit 100 times higher space is racist
movie wants you to know that whole face
guy had a family
please weep accordingly also oh my god
his face Marvin the Martian and Rubik's
Cube remind you that astronauts are
nerds in space no one can hear your dead
body floating harmlessly into frame
unless it's jump-scare time o2 down to
2% we're getting there beautiful don't
you think when her oxygen was at 8% he
was giving her stern instructions to
breathe slower and stop talking so much
but now that it's down to 2% he's like
get let's chat I had a daughter well of
course you did she was at school playing
tag it slipped eat her head where was
this game of tag being played in a
bathtub on an icy parking lot a rocky
field of banana peels the film gravity
should be renamed zero gravity her tank
went from 2 percent to 1 percent just
floating behind Kowalski for a few
seconds but somehow even after her tank
is empty she's fine freaking out
flailing around and gasping for air for
the minute or so after the tether breaks
the ropes are too loose I'm pulling you
with me you have to let me go or we both
die I see someone seen mission to Mars
besides me I mean mysteries of gravity
when Clooney releases Bullock's tether
he drifts away in zero-g
a single tug brings them together man
they gave Clooney the Steven Seagal an
executive decision treatment I see you
two alone oh now the movie remembers the
oxygen issue I bet it becomes an urgent
thing again too doesn't it okay you're
breathing co2 mysteries of gravity
astronaut Clooney informs medical doctor
Bullock what happens medically during
oxygen deprivation another way you see
that dot in the distance
mysteries of gravity how Hubble 350
miles up the International Space Station
230 miles up and a Chinese Space Station
are all in sight lines of one another I
don't want to hear you say you're gonna
make
yes let's waste time breath and precious
consciousness to boost her morale Ryan's
dad wanted a boy so much that the naming
process was settled even after she
turned out to be a girl beautifly
repeated but inverted dialogue interplay
cliche also you cannot build tension
about her life or death oxygen
consciousness situation and then pause
every few seconds for cute dialogue
that's called having your cake and
inhaling it too right you should see the
Sun on the Ganges you should also get
your ass inside the space station for
Christ's sakes
considering how slippery her grip has
been the last 20 seconds this
door-opening blast should have
definitely blown around a space to trade
afterlife stories with Clooney
hey wait weren't the silence come from I
mean why was there a super loud noise a
second ago out in space 20 full seconds
of gasping mysteries of gravity
why bollocks hair in otherwise
convincing zero-g scenes did not float
freely on her head heavy-handed womb
imagery our astronauts really barefoot
inside their space suits lucky as fire
extinguisher figures into the plot later
mysteries of gravity nearly all
satellites orbit earth west to east
yet all satellite debris portrayed
orbited east to west if you didn't see
this movie in 3d you missed an
opportunity for this scene to utterly
blow your mind and that's a sin on you
and I can hate 3d for what it's worth
also there goes HBO again and that's
gonna be out for a long-ass time I'm not
sure now all this space debris avoids
the escape pod but apparently it has the
same aim as bad guys in movies
understated one-liner after surviving a
crazy dramatic space debris storm a
medical doctor expertly and perfectly
executed agree course change burn in
spacecraft on first try Jesus even sugu
fucked up something the first time he
took out the enterprise ah the old
tapping the gauge reveals the actual
fuel level gag I actually haven't seen
that one in a while
space tantrum in space no one can hear
you scream but if you're a casual
observer on the outside of the escape
pod you can hear dr. Stone's muted
communication to Houston space is deadly
but earth sure is beautiful cliche
mysteries are gravity why we enjoy a
sci-fi film said and make-believe space
more than we enjoy actual people said in
real space and this movie really hits
you over the head with dr. Stone's
tragedy doesn't it with this movie be
less dramatic if her daughter were still
alive can you at least be a little less
heavy-handed about it Clooney ex machina
also movie figures out a way to give you
more Clooney even after his character
died there's nobody out there they can
hurt you it's safe well except for all
that satellite debris that keeps
rotating earth every 90 minutes with a
population of one inside the escape pod
even now the man gets credit for the
woman's idea she's so worried about that
shoe Matt is right under the bed sorry
to interject into this uplifting moment
in the film but the shoe was under the
bed what a tricky place for a shoe to
beat we interrupt this live action space
terror movie to bring you wall-e the
film gravity should be renamed angular
momentum
debris that should still be on its
original trajectory somehow falls fast
enough to target the Chinese space
station which is currently plunging into
Earth's atmosphere also the difficult
reentry isn't enough tension we have to
add even more tension again we've
already seen twice in this movie awesome
she survives the door opening blast
again she has a King Kong grip but only
when holding on to opening space doors
otherwise she's from butterfingers the
whole movie so ping pong huh is there
any way to play meaningful ping pong in
space trying to decide if this is
accurate prop management or just lazy
racism Brian who doesn't speak a lick of
Chinese just starts pushing buttons in
the hopes that one of them is the eject
this craft button and miraculously the
third pink button she punches is this
counter has 55 seconds on it when it
starts and then she begins her final
little Houston in the blind speech and
then we cut to win the craft separates
and it's in two full minutes after the
countdown began I'm just saying you want
Ryan to have a two-minute empowerment
speech at the end just write the
countdown timer to start at 1:55 instead
of 55 seconds Jesus we interrupt the
finale of gravity to bring you a quick
shot from Armageddon
I don't know the Chinese station was
losing altitude there were tons of
variables involving the escape pod and
whether it
done anything right it's an uncontrolled
re-entry and landing into a lake when it
could easily have hit ground this is one
of the luckiest escapes in movie history
we've already had her narrowly escaped
death about eleven times in this movie
but all the hell let's give it one more
go is right under the bed my tweets
hardly ever convey opinion mostly
perspectives on the world but if you
must know I enjoyed gravity very much
hey did you know Neil deGrasse Tyson
host star talk radio they have their own
YouTube channel and it's awesome
you will dig it if you like space or
science or staggeringly brilliant people
like Neil deGrasse Tyson or Bill Nye
many other special guests so check it
out you come and see some of what we do
here live and comment on it and check it
out and just hang out in the star talk
universe check it out and an absolutely
huge thank you to our special guest
narrator for gravity Neil deGrasse Tyson
you sir are welcome back anytime
hey I can see our hotel from here
detainer
Houston in the blind if I can take this
moment to thank Helga B um for not
letting me writing cards with boys till
I was 18 because she was right I would
have done what she said I was gonna do